die industrie kommt mit ihren veganen
ersatzprodukten immer näher ans original
dafür dass sie kompletten vegan ist
nicht schlecht sebastian lege deckt auch
wie viele zusatzstoffe im juni letters
vegetarian wasser stecken
es soll wie fleisch seien aber nicht aus
fleisch bestehen dass die kunst bei
diesen produkten wirklich neue ideen
entstehen in der regel außerhalb von
unilever dem trend zu vegetarischen
fleischalternativen hatte der
großkonzern zum beispiel lange
verschlafen
unilever löste das problem und kaufte
ein erfolgreiches startup auf fitte
terry butcher stellt burger pettys
chicken nuggets hühnerbrust streifen und
hackbällchen her alles vegetarisch alles
unikate beliebter fleischprodukte
der merger terry butcher sagt du musst
noch gar nichts verzichten sieht
schicken aus vegan
relativ fest neutrale masse leicht
vorgegart
da ist drin
63 prozent der basis trinkwasser
texturierte soja eiweiß weizen soja
vitamin b12
junge junge junge junge junge junge
junge das ist aber auch schon
produktentwickler sebastian lege weiß
die fortschritte bei der entwicklung von
fleisch ersatzprodukten sind riesig
deshalb testet er wie gut die neueste
produktgeneration gelungen ist
das nenn ich mal grillteller oder
und das ganze ohne fleisch
[Musik]
es ist schon so ein bisschen ein
brühwürfel
komm wir fangen wir mit der wurst an
macht man noch klassisch aus so erst mal
würstchen schauen wir mal das innenleben
an dafür schneide ich sie längst auf
das sieht der fasson sie das original
gar nicht so schlecht schneiden wir mal
an
könnte ein bisschen besser gewürzt sein
aber die ist dafür dass sie komplett
vegan ist nicht schlecht
die ist nicht schlecht
doch schnell ist klar das nachahmen von
echtem fleisch bleibt für hersteller
eine herausforderung
[Musik]
doch hier müssen sie einen geschmack
noch was tun auch sehr fad
gespann auf alle fälle am salz
und wie schneidet die hühnchen
alternative von unilever ab
hühner partie ist schon mal genauso
gummis teil wie wenn man richtiges
münchen nehmen würde auch das schneide
ich mal auf
ok da könnte man dann sagen okay das ist
kein fleisch und brustfleisch
das schneidet sich aber original wie
hühnchen
das ist schlecht
und hier wurde kein gewürz vergessen
[Musik]
kollege möchte metzger wie komme ich
jetzt auf die schliche das mache ich
nach und sie passen wir schön auf wie
das funktioniert patty bällchen
schnitzel oder nugget vegetariern butter
setzt auf nachgeahmte hähnchenfleisch um
verbraucher auf den geschmack zu bringen
aber bürger pittis aus hähnchen
beliebter sind doch die nuggets und die
machen wir jetzt
soja eiweiß ist das ausgangsprodukt
sebastian leser muss ein komplettes
arsenal an zutaten und zusatzstoffen
auffahren damit das so ähnlich wie
hühnchen wird wir müssen erstmal ein
gewisses gerüst schaffen das sorgt dafür
dass dieser widerstand da ist dass es
ein bisschen gummi heftig ist wie
gegartes fleisch gegartes hühnerfleisch
hat ja auch so eine elastizität das ist
ein bisschen komisch und wenn sie schon
mal so nah geht aufgebrochen haben dann
soll das ja auch so auseinander fächern
und das müssen wir damit simulieren
deswegen brauchen wir fasern wir haben
hier
kartoffel phase
dann haben wir hier noch zitronen faser
ja ist cremig ist aber aus zitrone
[Musik]
die faser kann man sich vorstellen wie
ein netz was man in einem produkt rhein
gibt was alles festhält das eiweiß die
gewürze die fette faser hält alles fest
insgesamt 22 zutaten stecken im
hühnerfleisch imitat von vegetariern
butchart alles um den fleisch ähnlichen
bis hin zu bekommen
[Musik]
jetzt brauchen wir platz zwei
da kommt das hühnchen
optisch erinnert die masse an gegart ist
klein gemahlenes hühnerfleisch
für den geschmack kommen noch aromen und
salz mit dazu
[Musik]
ja die soja schnitzel da drin wir haben
soja isolaten drin wir haben weizenmehl
pflanzenöl citrus faser kartoffel faser
mittellose modifizierte stärke normale
stärke gewürze essig pulver wollte ein
bisschen zeit fertig ist das coaching
damit die illusion von echtem fleisch
perfekt wird muss sebastian läge die
masse aus pflanzen eiweiß noch in die
typischen art form bringen und mit
wasser mehl und konflikts panieren denn
knuspriger panade ist einer der ältesten
tricks überhaupt um verbrauchern
fertigprodukte schmackhaft zu machen
da ist
mein sechs anlagen gutes gewissen keine
nun gestorben
[Musik]
im fall von vegetarischen produkten hat
panade einen weiteren vorteil
erst durch sie sind die fleisch imitator
optisch nicht mehr von echten zu
unterscheiden
ich bin ein bisschen stolz
hmm
schmeckt dynamik
und das ganz ohne hühnchen wahnsinn
dabei waren mehr als 20 zutaten für die
nugget imitaten nötig für die illusion
vom fleisch ein natürliches lebensmittel
sind damit nicht
[Musik]
trotz der hohen preise für fleisch
imitat greifen kunden immer öfter zu
was würde terry butcher und die
konkurrenz ein sie verlangen mehr als 16
euro pro kilo
in unserer stichprobe ist der
spitzenreiter plante chicken mit mehr
als 22 euro
damit sind die mieten teurer als echtes
fleisch ein bio eingibt es schon ab 12
euro das kilo und beim metzger kostet
ein konventionelles huhn knapp sieben
euro
[Musik]
vorteil mit jedem imitat bleibt einem
masten das leben in massentierhaltung
erspart
und trotzdem stehen fleisch imitator bei
experten in der kritik
der anstieg von sogenannten
fleischersatz produkten im supermarkt
zeigt eigentlich nochmal wie selbst ein
guter trend von firmen ad absurdum
geführt werden kann ich habe wieder
kleine verpackung es sind oft hoch
prozessierte produkte das heißt ich habe
zusatzstoffe die oft gar nicht gesund
ist auch hier habe ich zum beispiel
palmöl einsatz und das ganze wird wieder
in plastik verpackt
unilever feiert bald 100 jähriges
bestehen und einige seiner beliebten
marken sind sogar noch älter doch
allmählich wird immer klarer die
strategie mit der der konzern
jahrzehntelang erfolgreich war ist
ausgereizt
wenn man sich die produktpalette von uni
der war anschaut sind das natürlich er
lebensmittel die man nicht unbedingt
jeden tag essen sollte viele süßigkeiten
fertig suppen und saucen sehr sehr hoch
verarbeitet sollte nicht jeden tag auf
den tisch das heißt hier ihre viel
potenzial drin auch wirklich mal
gesündere produkte zu design und wenn
euch unsere videos gefallen und ihr
nicht genug kriegen könnt von unserem
besser ist dann gibt es hier noch mehr
videos und las amazon abonnieren -button
da ich würde mich freuen bis bald